[Musique]
à
mes chers compatriotes le choix que vous
allez faire le 22 avril prochain
engagera à la france pour longtemps
c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu que les
citoyens prennent la parole
je veux porter votre voix dans cette
élection présidentielle la politique
doit partir de la réalité de la vie des
gens être attentives aux leçons que le
peuple donne comprendre que le citoyen
est le mieux placé pour faire le
diagnostic de sa vie et pour dire au nom
de quelles valeurs
la gauche doit agir et de tout cela de
ces messages de détresse mais aussi
d'espérance
j'ai retiré le pacte présidentiel que je
vous propose aujourd'hui
oui retrouver le plein emploi et notre
objectif prioritaire
oui je veux réconcilier les français
avec l'entreprise
je veux aider les pme créatrices
d'emplois et donc de richesses
je mettrai en place une logique gagnant
gagnant qui soutiendra les entreprises
qui innovent qui exportent qui créent de
l'emploi
et je le dis ici très clairement les
entreprises qui délocalisent rond alors
qu'elles font des bénéfices ou qui
licencient alors qu'elles distribuent
des dividendes aux actionnaires devront
rembourser toutes les aides publiques
je ne veux pas non plus et vous non plus
je l' ai entendu vous me l'avez dit
d'une société dans laquelle le travail
rapporte moins que les revenus de
l'insistance je veux je ferai en sorte
que tous bénéficiaires des minima
sociaux qui reprend un travail voit ses
revenus s'améliorer
nous ferons en sorte et c'est
l'engagement que j'ai pris dans le pacte
présidentiel de relever le pouvoir
d'achat des petites retraites et des bas
salaires
la lutte contre la vie chère avec en
particulier le contrôle des abus
bancaires qui font basculer les familles
dans l'endettement et dans le
surendettement n'est plus tolérable
l'éducation sera au coeur de mon pacte
présidentiel
je veux être la présidente de la
réussite éducative et culturelle
je m'engage à mener la guerre à l'échec
scolaire aux enseignants qui se battent
en première ligne et qui sont les
artisans du pacte démocratique et
républicain je m'engage à porter soutien
reconnaissance et moyens pour leur
permettre d'exercer leurs missions
je veux mettre en place un service
public de la petite enfance et la
scolarisation dès l'âge de 3 ans je veux
un soutien scolaire gratuit pour chaque
élève
je donnerais à deux universités les
moyens de faire réussir les étudiants
avec davantage d'autonomie
les filières professionnelles seront
développés
notre sécurité sociale et menacer notre
système de prestations de plus en plus
inégalitaire
l'inégalité dans l'accès aux soins est
souvent redoublé aggravée par
l'inégalité entre les territoires
vous savez qu'il faut des mois dans
certaines régions pour obtenir un rendez
vous chez tel ou tel spécialiste
eh bien nous rétablirons l'égalité dans
l'accès aux soins
je créerai des dispensaires de proximité
dans les quartiers urbains et dans les
zones rurales isolées
j'ouvrirai une large négociations sur
l'avenir des retraites
les personnes âgées doivent en effet
pouvoir rester à leur domicile si elle
le souhaite le plus longtemps possible
et pour les personnes les plus
dépendantes
je veux augmenter le nombre de places et
la qualité des structures d'accueil
les défis de l'écologie ne sont pas une
limite mais c'est une formidable
occasion une opportunité de revivifier
nos économies et de stimuler la
recherche de créer de nouveaux emplois
de bâtir un monde plus vivable pour nos
enfants
je me présente devant vous forte de ses
engagements la france présidente c'est
celle du progrès pour tous et du respect
pour chacun vive la république vive la
france
[Musique]